Hi, I'm Sally and I'm going to give you some tips...
...on how to make the perfect meringue this Christmas.
First of all, you have to have a very clean bowl, and into it, egg whites.
Now, I always crack my eggs like this and then separate them through my hand.
Much, much less risk of breaking the yolk.
Now I'm going to start adding the caster sugar.
Just want to add very little at a time.
Sprinkle in some sugar and then whisk it in.
Look how glossy that is.
Really, really thick.
Now, my tip for knowing when you've really got that sugar mixed in it is just to feel it,...
...and if it isn't grainy anymore, you know you've whisked it perfectly.
That's gonna make great meringue.